bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors viktor orban
et rejette donc le projet européen de
conditionner les fonds au respect de
l'état de droit
pourquoi le fait-il parce qu'il ya
différents aspects à cette dispute au
sein de l'union européenne
c'est fondamentalement une lutte de
pouvoir une lutte de pouvoir entre les
états membres notamment entre les grands
et les petits états membres et en
particulier ceux qui sont contributeurs
nets au budget européen et au plan de
relance il est adopté et ceux qui
reçoivent les font alors le ceux qui
sont contributeurs nets c'est à dire
qu'ils donnent plus au budget qui ne
reçoivent par le moyen de de l'état de
droit
c'est une arme de pouvoir pour imposer
aux aux états qui reçoivent l'argent de
l'union européenne parce que eux-mêmes
contribue plus à ce budget de faire
pression sur leurs priorités
ensuite c'est aussi une lutte de pouvoir
entre grands et petits états membres
parce que les grands états membres comme
la france et l'allemagne
on imagine bien qu'avec une telle
procédure de surveillance sur l'état de
droit dans la rue dans les dépenses des
projets de l'union européenne il sera
impossible à mettre en minorité la
france ou l'allemagne de leur imposer
des sanctions de l'union européenne
parce qu'ils sont trop grands et ils
n'accepteront pas d'être mis en minorité
par contre les petits états membres s'il
ya une alliance assez large autour des
grands états membres mettre en minorité
par exemple la hongrie ou la pologne ce
serait plus facile donc la hongrie va
être très ferme sur cet aspect il ya
aussi un autre enjeu extrêmement
important c'est une lutte de pour vous
par aussi entre états membres sur les
les perspectives du projet européen les
finalités qui sont différentes par
exemple là
france et l'allemagne enfin les
gouvernements il s'agit pas des peuples
mais les gouvernements sont dans une
vision européenne qui privilégie la
promotion en fait de la démocratie
libérale avec ce qu'ils considèrent
comme l'état de droit ce fait partie des
valeurs de l'union européenne alors
qu'en fait il s'agit de normes de
gouvernance
tandis que les pays comme la pologne ou
la hongrie lorsqu ils sont rejoint le
projet européen après la chute du
communisme ont rejoint la civilisation
européenne pour eux le projet européen
ce n'est pas la défense de la démocratie
libérale des normes de gouvernement mais
c'est la défense de la civilisation
européenne de la nation avec des
frontières et des nations qui font
partie de la civilisation européenne
dont chrétienne et on voit bien que les
états membres qui défendent la
démocratie libérale comme l'allemagne en
particulier mais aussi le gouvernement
français veulent par exemple imposer à
la hongrie la pologne au moyen de l'état
de droit
l'ouverture des frontières le les quotas
de migrants la non discrimination des
minorités est évidemment entrent en
conflit géopolitique direct avec les
états à l'est de l'europe qui défendent
comme je les dis une vision totalement
différente du projet européen basé sur
une alliance de nations souveraines et
qui sont qui maîtrisent leur territoire
l'union européenne doit-elle avoir peur
alors de ce veto hongrois bien sûr
puisque je pense que ce sera extrêmement
difficile de de passer outre ce veto
hongrois et qui sera peut-être aussi
soutenu par la pologne parce que
évidemment le plan de relance et le
budget ne pourront pas être adoptés il
faut voir aussi que si les états membres
essayer de passer en force contre la
pologne et la hongrie les il devrait
aussi avoir une rare
si fication du plan de relance par les
parlements nationaux et la silla la
hongrie par exemple estiment qu'elle n'a
pas ses intérêts n'ont pas été pris en
compte pourrait faire à nouveau poser un
problème à ce plan de relance est donc
nous nous attendons en fait à à des
compromis et je pense que il restera
quelque chose de ceux de ce projet de
lier dépenses des fonds structurels avec
état de droit mais il sera tellement
édulcorée que ce sera difficile à le
mettre en oeuvre il faut voir aussi
j'estime que l'union européenne perd
beaucoup de temps dans ses détails sur
les valeurs soi-disant les valeurs alors
que alors que ce sont des normes de
gouvernement alors qu'en fait il ya des
mises en jeu bien plus graves dans
l'union européenne et par exemple la
france devrait peut-être plus mettre
l'accent sur le fait qu' est-ce que nous
français on contribue puisqu'on ne
reçoit au budget européen et des états
comme la pologne ou et ensuite d'autres
états membres qui vont recevoir beaucoup
de ce budget par exemple achète en
défense des f-35 américain et il
faudrait peut-être le lier à une
préférence européenne ce serait
extrêmement difficile mais si de toute
façon on se dispute sur des enjeux
autant se bat dessus des enjeux qui
compte vraiment pour une autonomie
stratégique européenne tient la manuelle
un thomann merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant en géopolitique et fondateur
du site internet
or au continent merci